hello everyone and welcome back to some
more action from the 38th European Club
Kappa we have a third round match
between uh board the one uh buen
maximovic representing chess club is
mine which translates the dragon and the
Magnus Carlsen for his Club over Spiel
uh you guys said that I've been
mispronouncing it like it's German I've
been saying oh freshpiel but it's
actually overspill which translates to
sacrificial play uh so sorry about that
I have no idea why I said office spill
just made sense to me but I now realized
that it completely doesn't and like I
said in the previous video uh this uh
this kind of a tournament is uh the only
opportunity someone who is let's say 300
over 300 rating points low rated than
Magnus uh will uh get to actually face
the the former world champion and the
highest rated player in the world as he
usually only plays close tournaments and
these few games a year that he plays for
his club offers Bill are you know a
great opportunity for lower rated
players who who are either Grand Masters
or in this case I believe boy and
maximovic is an international Master
yeah it says International Master here
so a great opportunity for him and the
opening that Magnus chooses for this
game is uh well not out of this world
because it has been played before uh by
some very well-known players it has even
been played against a world champion so
uh I don't know why Magnus chose it
probably to avoid Theory but also could
be other reasons so let's check it out
Bowen has the white pieces and he opens
with E4 and Magnus goes for none other
than Ponte A6 now this is called um
interest Theory the Saint George's
defense but of course uh we all we all
call it the Tony Miles because in the
European team championship of 1980 the
great Englishman Tony miles defeated
none other than then world champion
Anatoly karpov with this exact same move
and we have Pawn to D4 very principal
the reply taking the center as black is
playing weird moves and the miles played
B5 here against karpov uh and um B5 was
played in carpool with Knight to F3
nowadays it is known that you should
challenge the expansion and the queen
side with A4 right away but okay Ponto
D4 and Magnus goes on to E6 and with
this move uh basically it transposes
into the French defense with Knight to
F3 and pawn to D5 so it's pretty much uh
the same as if you had like E4 E6 D4 D5
and then Knight to F3 so uh pretty weird
move order of the French but probably we
should go like a knight beat the D2 and
C5 and now we get this like okay let's
say E4 was played then E6 the French
defends D4 D5 uh then the Knight defense
D4 Pawn with Knight B to D2 then Magnus
plays something like A6 let's say Knight
F3 and then Pawn to C5 so this is one of
the possible move orders and that Magnus
has played it before for example he had
this exact same position against Wesley
Soul only in that game he didn't play
Knight Pawn to C5 in that game he played
Knight to F6 and um the game ended in a
draw I was played in the Norway Blitz
championship of 2023 it's okay the
characters on C5 Photoshop characters
and now Bishop to D3 with Knight to C6
castles in Knight to F6 so this is now
already a very well known position we
have Queen E2 Queen to C7 and now e
characters and D5 Knight captures on D5
and Knight the E4 now putting pressure
on the bishop so Magnus brings it back
and here there is a game where Bishop to
C4 was played it was played in 1988
between Ilyas mirin and Alexei drev and
smiling lost this game after Bishop to
C4 but here we have Knight to G3 and it
is now already as of move 11 that we
have a completely new game so Magnus
continues development Bishop to D7 C3
and now Knight to F4 going after the
Bishops here now the you could capture
with this bishop or you could capture
with uh or you could just move the queen
and allow magnets to capture the light
Square Bishop so which Bishop do you
keep of course you are playing against
the French you keep the light Square
Bishop so Bishop captures an F4 Magnus
recaptures Rook 8 D1 we have rooked the
8 and now Rook F to E1 so completing
development Magnus castles and now Queen
to C2 putting pressure on magnus's Pawn
here now you could play G6 you could
play H6 you could even play a move like
King to h8 but when playing a lower
rated opponent king h8 is not a move you
want to make because uh someone who is
over 300 points already could go for
Bishop captures on H7 and once you trap
the bishop just give up the bishop for
three pawns here and you will have
excellent drawing chances
so after Queen to C2 G6 right away by
Magnus uh Ponte H4 and now King to G7 we
have Pawn to H5 and Magnus just plays
Bishop the C8 it's a very useful move it
defends the B7 pawn and also offers
trades of Rooks on the D file so Bishop
to E4 they're preparing to put pressure
on that B7 Pawn with Bishop E4 and queen
to B3 and the Magnus nicely trades Rook
characters real characters and now
Knight the E5 offering further trade so
now you slowly but surely get the idea
of what Magnus is trying to do his
pieces are somewhat optimally placed but
the problem of the French light Square
Bishop still exists and now look at this
light Square Bishop it's simply a
terrible piece you've seen how a bad
Bishop can influence your game in the
previous game where Magnus had the white
pieces in his light Square Bishop
completely dominated his opponent's
light Square Bishop but now Magnus will
have to fix this so Knights D2 going
after the queen Knight captures with
check Bishop captures and now Queen to
E5 a very nice centralizing move Queen
to B3 going after the B7 pawn and now
Magnus plays Queen to C7 G3 and now Rook
to d8 offering a Trader Rooks Magnus
wants the Rooks of the game and then he
will try to trade off the queen so Rook
captures Bishop captures and now H
characters and G6 whether you should
capture here or not it's um really um a
matter of a personal preference I would
say I would not capture uh some people
would capture uh I I just don't see what
you get by capturing and as long as it's
on H5 it's always uh a very annoying
Pawn because black has to calculate
every move whether you will capture or
whether you will try to sacrifice with
Pawn to H6 could be could be very
annoying so okay each characters and G6
H captors and now Knight to F4 so when
uh putting his pieces definitely on very
optimal squares and now Pawn to B6 by
Magnus we have Queen back to D1 and now
Queen to D7 Magnus offers a queen trade
which you should definitely avoid
because once the trade happens then and
the slide scorer Bishop definitely is in
the game and you have a bishop pair
against the bishop and the Knight with
play being on both sides of the board
and as Bishops can travel faster and
cover more squares than the Knight the
bishop pair will have the upper hand and
it's not like when you have a bishop
against the knight uh okay you can
definitely plug into the bishop pair is
a very very particular beast in chess
and it's never easy it's like a it's
like a more powerful Queen so Queen to
E2 avoiding the queen trade and now
Queen to D6 slowly but surely putting
the queen to a more Central Square
Knight to D3 and now Bishop to C7 with
Knight to B4 attacking A6 and now Pawn
to A6 and now you have to be careful if
you retreat with Knight to D3 Bishop A6
just wins the game on the spot there's
no way to defend if Bishop T4 you can
just attack it with F5 and the game over
so here Knight the C2 was played and now
Bishop to D7 with Knight to E3 and now
Pawn to B5 Magnus uh knows of course
that he has a disadvantage on the queen
side he has two points against three and
he wants to blockade the position on the
queen side so A3 and pawn day four now
magnus's A4 Pawn is basically
controlling these three pawns so King to
G2 we have Pawn to F5 now you have to be
very careful when making a move like
this but Magnus calculated that his King
will be safe with Queen the C2 and now
comes Bishop to B6 now you could go for
F4 right away of course uh and you can
even open up the white king but the
white king is fairly safe here let's
take Queen D3 and you could even throw
in a one check but it doesn't really do
all that much so instead Magnus plays
Bishop to B6 again he's optimizing his
Bishops uh with Queen back to E2 and now
Pawn to E5 beautiful uh just controlling
a whole lot of squares here uh preparing
Ponte for to trap the light Square
Bishop so one has to move it either to
B7 or maybe to A8 or you could move the
king death one sort of to make room for
the bishop but it's gonna be a very
passive Bishop there so Bishop to A8 and
now upon the E4 now the bishop is kind
of stranded on E8 and you should be
careful uh so the the black queen
doesn't capture in some It capture it
somehow but this allows the knights to
be re-maneuvered Knight to the D5 and
now Bishop to A7 again Magnus keeping
his Bishop pair in the game now the dark
Square Bishop is a magnificent piece for
the moment the light Square Bishop not
so much just yet so Magnus is still
fighting to make this bishop a useful
piece that's how uh big of a problem the
light score Bishop is in the when you
play the French so if if you play the
French and if you ever have an
opportunity to trade off your light
Square Bishop for your opponent's light
score Bishop you of course will very
very gladly do that yeah and now we have
Knight the B4 now here you should uh
consider this advancement of the pawn
with Pawn to C4 as it just um you know
forces magnets to make a decision so
let's say B captors Queen captures and
if the Queens get traded captures
characters captures okay it's still
um a bishop pair against the bishop at
night but you do have the two to one
advantage on the Queen side and you
should be able to hold this you're going
to play something like Knight back the
C3 have constant pressure on the save
for pawn and uh well you should have
excellent drawing chances but he went
for Knight to B4 and now Magnus plays
Bishop to C5 with Bishop to B7 uh he he
uh this is basically as he was a very
long time this already moved 40 so time
control has been reached he was below
five minutes uh when he reached time
control so he did gain additional uh 30
minutes but Magnus was up on the clock
like 30 minutes so Magnus is now around
has an around an hour on the clock and
one has some half an hour on the clock
and uh I believe this was uh this this
series of moves were made in order to
avoid mating some sort of a drastic
change in the position so he just wants
to hold everything but it's you know as
they say uh you know you're not gonna uh
be able to plug into Magnus by doing
nothing so King to H6 Magnus now puts
his King on a safer square and now he's
preparing something very special but I'm
not going to tell you what it is you
guys will tell me what it is so Bishop
to A8 there's just no useful move uh
buang can make uh Bishop to E8 now this
is a this is a top class move and I'm
sure you guys already realize why Bishop
d8 was played now one goes for Pawn to
C4 and now Queen to D for putting more
pressure on this F2 pawn and here is
just uh well uh there's no move you can
make let's say you go Knight to see do
you try to try to give up the B2 Pawn
for maybe some Queen to D2 action and
then somehow getting the queen into the
game of course Magnus would ignore the
B2 Pawn he would just play Queen D3 and
now look at this queen captures e
captors this is uh a bad situation for
the Knight if you go to E3 the bishop
will just capture it and then you
advance the pawn to Victory so you're
gonna have to go night before but not
just Bishop captures eight captures and
D2 and if you block with Bishop to F3
okay you are guarding this but now B
captures and C4 and once you get the
king enter game C3 ends the game B
captors and A3 is now Unstoppable so
after this queen to D4 move one made his
last stand he played Bishop to D5 but
now comes magnus's idea if you've been
closely following what Magnus did on the
few couple of moves you will find in
this move without without a problem if
not you will need a longer pause the
video moment so feel free to pause the
video and try to find the only winning
move for Magnus while I give you a
couple of seconds
uh so for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding the
true idea behind Bishop to E8 and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show uh it is spawn to G5 this is the
movie that shatters White's defenses F4
is now coming and also Bishop to H5 is a
huge huge threat uh as it will attack
the Queen the queen is stuck here
guarding the the F2 Pawn there's just no
way out of this so he Bon of course
finds a way there is but one Knight to
C6 this keeps him in the game but Queen
D3 offers a queen trade and now he's out
of options here as uh if you move the
queen somewhere weird then Queen F would
be one B1 and you will start gobbling up
the pawns here so Queen captures e
captures and now King the F1 the problem
is if you go Knight to the E5 uh just
going after the pawn and D1 Bishop to F3
uh Bishop to D4 attacks the Knight and
you will start gobbling up the queen
side pawns and then the queen side pawns
will decide the game so here King to F1
and now B captures on C4 this is also uh
one part of the tactic as the C4 Pawn
cannot be captured at the Knight on C6
is hanging tonight the E5 and now Pawn
to D2 King the E2 now the king also
helps out but now Bishop captures an F2
and look at this uh Bishop pair I mean
the light Square Bishop still uh kind of
uh not doing all that much but uh the
but the potential of the light screw
Bishop became so so impressive because
now you have to pass deep on in Bishop
to H5 check would allow it to Queen
Under D1 Square so you can attach the
bishop otherwise you just Castle sorry
promote uh G4 here uh trying to to mess
up a magnus's pawn structure but now
Bishop to D4 attacking the Knight and
the pawn here Knight captures on C4 and
now F characters and G4 so giving up
this Pawn to create a pass Pawn on the G
file and now the G1 square is already
guarded King captures sanditio Pawn to
G3 and now King to D3 attacking the
bishop and now look at this bishop to f
7. finally the bishop plays a useful
move although it had a great potential
for the entire game now it's just you
know this bishop is saying this bishop
is hanging and Magnus will of course
gladly give up bull Bishops to promote
this Pawn to a queen so you cannot move
the Bishop from this diagonal Bishop
back to G2 now comes Bishop to F6 uh
Knight the B6 going after the A4 pawn
and now Bishop to B3 defending and
creating a wall here against the white
king so the white king cannot defend the
B-2 Pawn so King to E3 now Bishop
captures some B2 with Bishop to C6 going
for the A4 pawn and while you could play
Pawn to G2 sorry well he could play
Bishop captures on A3 then you would uh
maybe uh you know the A4 Pawn would be
vulnerable so Magnus shifts the
attention to the a pawn he now
sacrifices the G2 Pawn so first he give
up the D2 Pawn now he gives up the G2
pawn and then he will uh create a past a
for Pawn also with a tactic with a with
a very nice tactic uh sorry G2 Bishop
captures sanjit you have to take this
now Bishop characters and A3 and the
problem is you cannot defend with Bishop
to C6 to go after the pawn because
Bishop the C5 check wins the Knight on
B6 so also another unfavorable Square
for the king king the D3 was played but
now Magnus is in time this should beat
you creates a wall against the white
king and now the pawn is marching
forward Bishop to D5 only way to
continue with Bishop captures Knight
captures and pawn to A3 and he was in
this position on move 61 that Brian
maximovic resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here and now for
those of you who enjoy uh me finishing
the the and the positions I will show
you why this is winning uh the the
reason is you have to uh defend against
both of these pawns and once you okay
King C2 of course you wanna
keep an eye on the A2 square but now G4
and after King to B3 will play G3 and
after Knight the defends you will just
bring your king into the game King to
c2s you really don't have a move here
King F4 and ig2 check you'll play King
F3 Knight Dage for checking F2 and now
King to B3 you will push this Pawn at
the Knight will have to sacrifice itself
for the pawn and now okay if it was a
light Square Bishop of course this would
be a draw as you could not defend the
queening square but Magnus has a dark
Square Bishop so it's completely winning
uh so King to A2 King to F3 King to B3
and now the the black king just comes
closer King to D3 King to B3 doesn't
really matter Bishop to C1 King A2 King
to C2 and after King day one king to B3
King to B2 and now you simply give a
check and if you capture the bishop you
get a queen and if you play King to A1
of course Bishop the b2's Checkmate so
this is only one way you could finish
this but I'm sure you guys would not
have a problem winning this against the
Magnus himself if needed uh so yeah
that's the game very nicely done by both
of them Bland played a a great game and
he handled this um a provocation by
Magnus Asics and beginning very very
professionally like I said he's not a
professional player he's uh I believe a
third year student of uh maybe something
like engineering I'm not sure uh and you
know holding uh Magnus this long in a
classical game is just very very very
impressive so I'm pretty sure you know
Buon is If he if he took uh chess
seriously and if he you know uh
dedicated more time to chess I'm pretty
sure he could play pretty much against
anyone as this was um you know very very
impressive play against the the
strongest player possibly who ever lived
Magnus Carlsen uh but yeah Magnus uh
played faster uh Bon had to make some
decisions that simply weren't optimal
and Hereafter Bishop to D5 Magnus and
you guys of course found Pawn to G5 and
after that you know it's just a very
well played game but yeah Magnus played
every move the top engine move pretty
much and that's what it took the table
and down so you know that props the
blend for for holding his own against
um Magnus here uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it uh a very
nice time we'll see what happens if you
get if you have some other favorites
from the European Club cup do you use
hashtag suggestion and I will go over
them I would like to thank robertun
and Mr hoodie guy for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World and sorry about no
videos yesterday my voice really wasn't
working but today it is feeling better
so there you have it uh Magnus wins
again yesterday we had a master class uh
good Bishop that bishop and here we have
a sort of an opposite Master Class where
Magnus plays with the bad Bishop but you
know if you give it time your bad Bishop
will become a good bishop or you will
give it up for your opponent's useful
piece or something you just don't want
to uh you know lose the game before that
happens that's that's the secret to
winning with bad Bishops obviously yeah
once again really hope you enjoyed it uh
um and yeah thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day